ja hallo wer ist da ja hallo mein Name
ist Luca ich wollte nur kurz fragen ob
ich da mit dem 21 April 2005 verbunden
bin ja warum weil an dem Tag ja
Nintendogs rauskamen und ich habe einen
YouTube-Kanal und ich habe das
Spiel ist ja aber ich wollte das jetzt
vielleicht mal wieder hochladen auf
meinem Kanal wirklich sagen dass sie
keine andere Video die haben als ein 18
Jahre alte Spiel nein
[Musik]
hallo willkommen im Nintendogs Zwinger
wir schauen uns erstmal die Hunde an die
wir hier heute zu Besuch oh ein
verwöhnter Welpe der keine fremden mag
aber sein Herrchen über alles liebt ich
frage mich allen du hast dein Hündchen
gewählt
[Musik]
ey diese Musik
Wahnsinn dass er mich direkt an die Zeit
wo ich ein Kleinkind war also vorgestern
ist nun bei dir zu Hause es scheint ein
wenig nervös zu sein weil die Umgebung
fremd ist dementsprechend müssen wir
jetzt unseren Hund hier so ein bisschen
anrufen dass er auf uns zugelaufen kommt
und wir gehen jetzt ein bisschen
streicheln können
man kann auch
will der mich jetzt ein Bad lifting
zeigen oder was
ich kann heulen die alten Nintendogs
Videos erscheint sich etwas beruhigt zu
haben sicher ist dir schon ein Name für
ein Hühnchen eingefallen oder
Mayo
ähm Mario
wie oft muss man das denn machen Mario
ey du kannst langsam mal einen Namen
merken oder
endlich ey der ist ja genauso blöd wie
ich aber er hat wenigstens diese Pfoten
er hat sich den Namen gemerkt notiere
ihn bevor du oder dein Hund ihn
vergessen wahrscheinlich vergessen
y o der Name des Hundes lautet Mario der
mario ist jetzt bei uns zu Hause hallo
dich schütteln im Wohnzimmer Mario
guck mal an checkt er direkt der kleine
Racker hier guck mal ein bisschen
gestreichelt komm jetzt Glitzer hier
schön wir müssen jetzt den Namen von
Marion ein bisschen öfter rufen so dass
er sich halt daran gewöhnt Mar
hey na alles klar halt deine Schnauze du
kleiner super schöne Zeit hier sehen sie
können den später erscheint den Namen
vergessen zu haben du solltest ihn ihm
nochmals bei das ist nicht euer ernst
oder wenn sich da sind 387 Stunden
später
oh mein Gott und jetzt vergisst du den
nicht nach einer Minute wieder
mal oh mein Gott endlich kann man hier
weitermachen ich bin in der Rohraufnahme
bei 47 Minuten dies ist ein guter
Zeitpunkt deinem Hund als Kommando sitzt
genau so wie der Name
und dieses Mikrofon
[Musik]
gelernt notiere dass du eben erlernte
Kommandos
oder so es scheint als würde Mario
definitiv auf deine Stimme reagieren das
ist Cap das wissen wir alle nun gelernt
hat zu sitzen kannst du auch andere
Kommandos probieren kann ich auch sein
lassen
[Musik]
da sind wir zu Hause mit Mario
mit Mayo ach guck mal er hat es gelernt
jetzt
[Musik]
Sitz
dieser Typ ne der regt mich so auf ja
komm Leute wir lassen den Mario mal da
hinten mit dem Ball ein bisschen
rumspielen das war die erste Episode
Nintendogs seit sieben Jahren habe ich
das nicht auf meinem Kanal hochgeladen
habt ihr Bock auf den nächsten Part wo
ich mit Mario vielleicht mal ein
bisschen spazieren gehe wo wir
vielleicht auch für Wettkämpfe
trainieren oder ihm neue Kommandos
beibringen
ich glaube allerdings da haben wir alle
keinen Bock drauf
[Musik]